[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby
and tonight we have a special third
edition of the road
2000 tournament so this is you the
viewers at home
uh this is your chance to prove yourself
prove that you are learning things in
the road to 2000
and fight for some pretty fun prizes i
think
uh this time around the prize is a big
raffle
that's going to take place on our
massive bill wright st
louis open tournament we're going to be
giving away all sorts of stuff i think
so definitely check that one out on st
louis chessclub.org
and this is one sort of lead-in
tournament to that so we're hoping to
make that one a big success
it's a lot of fun every year it has to
be online this year
but we're still thinking it's going to
be a really fun time i
do believe resident gm steven zurich
will be competing in that one
as well so it's going to be a lot of fun
you should check it out
before that though we do have our
tournament tonight so there is a link in
the chat i'm going to post it again
that is the link to our club on
chess.com
to play in the tournament you go to that
link click join
click on the tournament and bam you're
already there
so you do have something like 13 more
minutes left to sign up and in the
meantime
i wanted to get everybody's brains
working with a little bit of
an end game puzzle and now this is a
pretty unique endgame puzzle
because i came across it in the wild i
was just randomly
on chess.com believe it or not uh
watching i
believe a twitch stream and the the
streamer was following some random 15
minute game
and the players got to a position much
like this i swapped some things around
so that the puzzle uh works a little bit
better
but almost exactly like this and i
noticed
an incredible winning idea that was
actually missed
during the game so it's black to move
here and black of course needs to deal
with this knight
and has to somehow stop these white
pawns
from prevailing and believe it or not
here it's actually black to move
and win now normally in a position like
this you would think hey
this bishop has these pawns pretty well
stopped the g
pun in the way as well no way black is
going to win this in fact black should
be lucky
to get away with a draw but in fact
black does actually have a winning idea
here so as i said
it starts with king to e3
and now white really only has one try to
survive and that is the move
a4 white needs to get these pawns
rolling as quickly as possible to even
stand a chance
and now i want to ask you guys at home
if you can find black's first
idea in this position and it's quite a
long sequence of moves here so we'll
take it sort of one step at a time
but black to move here see if you can
warm yourself up uh
before the tournament starts in 12
minutes but do please
be joining this event i'm hoping it's
bigger than ever before and i'm noticing
a lot of familiar faces
i'm seeing a steve north in there i'm
seeing a manny
lp in there i think indiana jones is one
fan favorite ali chandra from the chess
club
uh and yeah samuel bryce also ringing
about so
fun people in the tournament already i'm
looking over here i'm not joining myself
that would be a bit unfair
i'm just your host tonight so if you
want some commentary on your games and
you want to
join this big raffle be sure to join up
now in the meantime though
ah yeah ben with the close-up here 11
minutes to go
join up join the club it's on chess.com
not leeches yes
maybe i'll have to talk to mike about
getting uh some leeches tournaments
going
but for now we are here on chess.com
so in the meantime though this chess
puzzle manny has the right idea
just f3 he says as if it is so
simple but f3 is the idea now this
actually puts white into a little bit
of an awkward position if white captures
with the pawn
suddenly g2 and g1 is unstoppable
now if white captures with the bishop
this at first glance seems to get the
job done that's why the bishop is there
but black of course can take and white
again is unable to take
due to the threat of promotion however
as you may know chess actually has
different rules than the game of
checkers despite sharing the same board
and captures are not forced in chess
depending on who you ask
if they're playing checkers correctly
they might not think they're forced in
checkers either but
regardless g takes f3 in this instance
definitely not forced and that's why
white needed to get these pawns rolling
to stop black's idea with the knight so
after a5
black's job gets a lot harder just
because you won a piece
doesn't mean you necessarily won the
game
so black to move again here we have to
come up with another winning idea
and this is the stunning idea that was
actually missed
so learn chess with inion has the right
first move and that is to abandon
the pawn on g2 altogether if black gets
greedy
and tries to go upon grabbing
unfortunately
white is going to be just in time we
can't even check
to make a queen and after g2 white is
actually going to be able to stop this
pawn
and go on to win the position so knight
h4 not the right idea we actually do
have to use the knight
to stop these pawns and now white of
course should continue pushing with a6
we want to lock this knight down as much
as possible
knight b5 and then of course white is
going to play
king to e1 so we've had a little bit of
a back and forth here
white black has this great idea with f3
but white
sort of counter punches with the a pawn
rush black seems to have been just in
time to stop the pawns
but how can we actually play for more
here black to move
and again find a winning idea
a winning idea what can we do
osama rada says i have an important game
tomorrow against an opponent stronger
than me how could i prepare
boy oh boy could you prepare by
competing in this
seven round three minute blitz
tournament starring national master
caleb denby
uh i will do commentary on all the games
let you know
what's going on in all seriousness
though i
i like to just review my openings the
day before a match no not necessarily
trying to do a bunch of prep
for my specific opponent but just
reviewing what i already know making
sure it's fresh in my mind
maybe i'll solve a few tactics just to
get in the habit of
good calculation habits and you know
just just in the right frame of mind for
for a chess game
that's the key the day before a match
you're not going to completely improve
your chess
in one day so just to make sure you feel
fresh make sure chess is in your mind
and you can play your best hello adi i
see you in the tournament adi
i'm looking forward to it
manny loves this puzzle if black wins so
great wolf has has the right first idea
our king is optimally placed if we try
to move anywhere
white is just going to meet us and we're
not making much progress right
on e3 our king threatens to step to d2
and f2 very importantly so we move the
knight
now white is forced to either play king
f1
and allow us to step in or play b4 first
either way it sort of transposes black
is going to pass
again now king d1 obviously loses to
king f2
and king f1 allows the black king in
but that of course is not the end of the
story right now white is in the same
situation where white must move again
and just for reference by the way this
endgame does
in fact lose believe it or not
it might not be apparent y right away
white can run to the corner don't play
king f2 because that'll be stalemate
but we do actually have a nice winning
idea here
which of course
[Music]
is hold on i think i have to waste a
tempo
hold on we're going to get there
the winning idea of course is to play
knight f3 in this position
which that's sort of a whole puzzle on
its own but you still make the white
king
force captures and then you can step to
f2 and promote
believe it or not that's the only
winning idea i've actually found in that
position
so white sacking the pawns not playable
which again
sort of a puzzle in itself but it's sort
of intuitive
that it can't work somehow extra piece
is usually enough
so then white goes king f1 and we end up
in this position where white cannot
sacrifice the pawns
has to go with king h1 and now
of course king f2 or king f1 or move the
knight again what does the chat room
think
black to move and win we are arriving at
the final idea here
with just five minutes left to join the
tournament five minutes left
click the link in the chat join up
absolutely easy next so yeah easy idea
of white sacks the pawns everybody saw
knight f3 coming a mile away
and now the real idea as they say
andrew wang says try to mate and that is
the right way to think
but how do we checkmate here
how do we checkmate yeah you have the
right idea andrew but
tell me the specifics how does it work
what's the first move
and then what's the next move
okay manny has an idea king f1 knight c3
knight d1 knight f2 and this is actually
where the players
in the game made an unfortunate mistake
in the game black played the move king
f2 and the game
was soon drawn king of two of course
being much worse than king f1
because we need that square for our
knights i
don't think chess.com lets me draw the
arrows but we need the knight here to
deliver checkmate so king f1 of course
is the move
but manny you got the idea slightly
wrong don't forget
the a pawn is going to make a queen and
it's quite difficult
to checkmate black if white has a queen
on the board so what do we do
how do we improve
how to improve
hello adrian hello if you're just
joining please
please please click on the link that's
pinned in the chat
i'm also just going to post it again
click on that link
join our chess.com club and play in this
tournament
there's a big raffle up for grabs as a
part of the bill wright st
louis opening open not opening coming up
uh in the next
month i think i think it's in april uh
or maybe later this march actually go to
our website check it out maybe ben can
do some research
march 13th it's so soon oh my god join
the bill right it's next week it's going
to be a lot of fun
so of course we take the pawn and then
after b5
now black's moves become rather forced
and white
is doomed by the virtue of having a b
pawn left of course we do not take
as this is still mate in one we don't
hang our knight but we go
knight c8s knight d6
knight e4 and just in time
to deliver the checkmate what a wild
idea
and this is probably the closest to a
composed end game puzzle i've ever like
seen happen just in a random live chess
game
this one is honestly a wild idea
and to make matters worse just confuse
things with the last couple minutes here
let me see if i can update the position
slightly
this one's a draw and the reason is that
incredibly after the exact same line
here we go king e1 knight a7 white plays
the astounding move
b3 and then the tempe just don't work
out
knight b5 b4 and now of course
white sacrifices the b pawn before
allowing the king in
and white no longer has this b pawn
playing against
him and of course here black is a move
too slow to deliver the checkmate
incredible stuff
what a position white doomed because the
pawn is on b3
don't see that one every day but the
wasted tempo here allows white to draw
really fun stuff this is one of my
favorite endgame positions i've ever
just randomly come across
but with that in mind that's enough of
me talking join the tournament
you have so little time you have 40
seconds on your screen
in in my screen you have a like a minute
extra so go
join this link join our tournament it's
going to be a lot of fun we've got 18
players in there
and manny is the top seed manny
with the big rating oh no man he's not
the top seed
it just needed to update we've got
patricio
bq from uh mexico we've got andy ruya
ap truth posada i don't recognize these
names oh unless this is
i i do know one andy who watches watches
the stream that could be him
but we do have manny we have st louis
chess boxing that's exciting i don't
know who that is
um but i'm always up for some chess
boxing
as long as i'm not you know a player
i'll commentate some chess boxing
[Music]
do you have to checkmate can you take
both pawns move the king to f2 the
problem with moving the king to f2 in
that position is that it's always
stalemate the king is on h1 king is on
f2 and the white king cannot move
um okay though join up we have 21
players 40 seconds left
let's do it let's do it
21 players i don't think this is going
to be a record i think you can
late join just just by a round or two
but of course you're off to a slow start
then so join up now before it's to and
we lost a player well i was talking i'm
the worst
i'm not doing a great job we're down to
20. i undersold it
undersold it join now well you can
the real prize is hearing me commentate
your games
all right 10 seconds we're getting ready
to go here i think we're gonna keep an
eye on board
one to start with because patricio
versus andy is looking to be
a pretty fair fight both with exactly
the same rating
and here we go games are in progress oh
of course they just do it swiss style
so we don't get to see that but we do
get to watch boardroom one here let's
see how patricio
does see curt with a tough first round
pairing up against seed number one
looks like we have a sicilian with a
knight c3 move
okay so it looks like a slower approach
yeah white chooses not to play d4
plays d3 instead keeping the center
closed
uh and yeah we just have a normal
closest silly now with bishop f4 bishop
f4 looks slightly strange to me to be
honest
don't know what this bishop is doing
here maybe white's playing for some kind
of quick e5
against d6 that could be it to my
knowledge
the only real plan in the closest
sicilian that i know of is this
fianchetto castle
and then you know clown push on the
king's side but maybe white has
something else in mind
and early d5 for black is generally a
good way
to combat this opening i feel with black
breaking in the center
now white's you know whatever white's
ideas were
they're a little bit tougher to enact
and that's why we do see e5
and yeah maybe maybe white had a point
but
now this pawn is attacked many times i
can't count can you count there's too
many pieces
it's tough
okay maybe d4 from white but c takes d
could be played and i think white might
be on the fast track to losing a pawn
here
okay if knight takes the knight is
attacked but the knight can step back
there's pressure on the d5 pawn but is
it enough
knight takes c6 is just b takes c6 you
still don't have enough pieces on the e5
square
looks like an extra pawn for black let's
continue on then i want to check out
my good friend adi's game it looks like
board 2 has already finished
i don't know how that's possible in the
first minute of play board 2 seems to
have finished
incredibly leaving pb diamond with the
full point
maybe maybe andy didn't show up to the
game could be
could be all right we've got oddie with
the white pieces here
battling against ap truth audi the
underdog in this game
plays g3 i don't know if it was strictly
necessary to blunder this
exchange i think rook f2 probably would
have gotten the job done now we see h5
and h4 coming audi plays h4 himself but
this is going to lose this pawn
this is going to lose it king h1 is
played and this
looks quite dangerous there's
checkmating threats in the air now
i definitely think king h2 was the more
responsible choice
for audi in this case adi of course
being indiana jones
2020 and that is checkmate ah
tough game tough game for audi to start
out with you know i have to check out
stl chest boxing with a name like that
um
i feel like i should know who this
person is but i just don't and i'm also
wondering if there's some underground
chess boxing ring in st louis that i
just don't know about could be
interesting
chess boxing is illegal in st louis my
goodness we're watching a criminal
watching a criminal play and well the
criminal
stl chest boxing uh doing illegal
chest boxing activities is actually down
a queen in this position
but i i guess is trying to claim some
compensation
although this is looking a lot like
checkmate me the beast
perhaps an underrated opponent here
perhaps underrated clicking back to our
board one here
things have developed somewhat black has
completely taken over the center
and that's the issue with hanging a
center pawn in almost any opening
it's not just that you're down a pawn so
you're down a center pawn
and then things like this start to
happen the bishop on f3 gets trapped
e3 d3 all very good moves looks tough
all right we've got h3
by white of course though this is
blundered on e3
and this one appears to be in the bag
for black how did this queen get lost
what happened we had some sort of crazy
scotch
sacrifice this is like some this this is
some jonathan schrantz opening
this is some jonathan trance opening i
don't know what's going on here
oh and then white perhaps was pre-moving
i don't understand how you blundered
this queen like this that's quite sad
quite sad the opening appeared to go
well for white but then
all is lost or is it we have a queen
blunder
back in return fortunately for black
still up
a full rook and peace but
steal chess boxing you know it's tough
to count anybody who chest boxes
out they'll just get back up start
punching in the head
it's not so easy it's quite a violent
sport
okay we have f6 and rook e8s now f7
and bold play by white but black should
just be able to corral this pawn now
perhaps a case of pushing a bit too far
will we see black capture we will but
with the bishop putting himself in this
awkward pin i don't know
king e7 is required but it's found and
white's just running out of pieces here
white's running out of pieces
perhaps the clock is the idea if i'm
black
i am taking off the rooks taking on b4
and taking off the rest of the pawns i'm
a 900 player
i just want all the pawns gone so i know
that i'm not gonna lose on time
at the very least it is a draw
so yeah if you're black here you just
you gotta take off all the pawns
you know what i mean like maybe you
don't find checkmate in 14 seconds but
you can at least take all the stuff
and make sure you're not losing the game
this is important and we do see
that the clock may be in stl's favor
here
although black is is picking up the pace
picking up the pace now
uh b2 with check if black white had
played king c3
this pawn could have been captured and
now i think
white is searching for some stalemates
will
they find it no it's the latter white is
getting laddered
and that is the match perhaps the upset
of the round here by me to beast
interesting to see and with that i do
believe the first round is coming to a
close
we have maybe one game remaining and yes
we do
and we are about to witness the flagging
of rohit and
that is that another huge upset it's a
good day to be a 900
900 rated chess player and with that i
believe round two
should be getting underway and it is
we do have our board one uh patricio bq
winning the first game and now taking on
tol bridge troll not the easiest name in
the world
to pronounce and playing the
scandinavian
all right we have the queen a5 line of
course these skandy players are doing
all sorts of funny things with their
queen these days
but the simple move queen a5 is usually
thought to be the best
an early d5 by white it's quite an
interesting one i wonder if this pawn
will be a little bit overextended
or if the awkwardness of black's pieces
will come into play here
and yeah we see black sort of
responsibly just retreating this knight
back to g6
and now uh bishop b5 check is is going
to force some concessions
okay we have c6 but why not captures why
not captures
now this is a threat i don't know what
the plan is here for black we might see
an early victory out of patricio e5
but this move comes with check and comes
with a new queen
i don't know if white even needs to
respond to this threat although i'm
i'm sure it's fine if white does and we
do just see c takes b7
with check to the black king this king
is going to move somewhere
king e7 there's this check there's
just the simple move queens looks tough
looks tough i'm gonna flip off of this
game i think patricio has this one
in the bag let's check out manny's game
manny against one of the scary 900s who
upset
their uh much higher rated opponents in
round one
we seem to have a caro khan this is in
fact a caro khan
and black black allowing bishop takes f5
is a pretty big mistake here i think
pretty big mistake while in many
positions
um this structure on the king side can
be quite solid for black
this is definitely not one of them in
order to do stuff like this you need a
white's pawn to be back here
once it gets to e5 it's pretty scary
this pawn is going to go to e6 someday
and cause you all sorts of problems we
also see c4
by black and perhaps the idea is to just
go pawn grabbing
on b2 maybe not though maybe not
and yeah the problem now for black is
you just always have to keep an eye on
this square
maybe black has some grand design of
putting a knight on this square but we
actually already see manny
making some subtle threats and now
deliberating if this pawn should be
captured
in order giving up the pawn on b2
and manny decides it is meant to be
this pawn can be captured on b2 but with
the king in the center i think you do
have to be quite
quite careful quite careful i don't want
to give too much away here but maybe
maybe some of this is going to happen
and that's why we see queen e6 instead
by black going for the solid approach
although black now is just down a pawn
and with c4 played you really did need
to do something
on this queen side now you've simply
closed the center
for white white no longer has to fear
anything against the d4
pawn and with an extra pawn i think
white is
quite happy in this position to say the
least
and easy development now for white
although this is a
pawn perhaps there's a counter pawn here
but this is check i don't know
i don't know maybe not so simple after
all manny
a bit confident starts losing pawns i
get the feeling though that this should
be the move
stepping out of the check and again
threatening some
some stuff
tight game here in the meantime we do
see patricio
winning this game uh i think that the
checks were given we see queen c5 queen
d5
and then up a rook with two queens
and about to take off black's other
queen uh
tolbridge troll had had enough
uh let's continue on though let's
continue on how is the other
surprise uh winner doing now let's check
out restless behaviors game
restless behavior taking on the chess
boxer
in round two and this looks to be an
interesting one what happened to white's
e-pawn
okay it captures on d5 we have a fried
liver attack
mike would be proud and now they're
retreating
for white's pieces knight g6 is a weird
one
okay that's a peace sacrifice
and now oh more pieces are falling
there's g3 the bishop goes now a fork
oh and that's checkmate oh god and i
hear a certain restless behavior
shouting from the other room so sad so
so sad
and checking back in on this game
perhaps the unsung hero of the game for
black
may be the clock situation manny with a
good position but spent a lot of time to
get there
will 16 seconds be enough against the
dangerous ding ratool
92 will it be enough gotta go fast we
have king e3
and this move blunders the pawn but the
important thing is black made the move
quickly
if black continues to make moves quickly
i wouldn't count them out of this game
should defend this pawn now maybe maybe
defend
and black okay taking their time now
taking their time
uh which is sometimes the the correct
flagging technique you just want to make
sure hey
i've got the time i'm going to make sure
i don't lose the game
oh king g6 doesn't quite feel right a
quick d5 by manny i think knight takes
d5
was perhaps a miss there and
i think now yeah the pawn has to be
given up but manny's getting another one
c4 is also hanging but seven seconds on
the clock okay we see some complications
now both knights on priests
as the french say and both knights are
taken manny with two past
pawns has a quick route to pushing them
but
is the route quick enough for 6.8
seconds
that being said black also going down on
the clock now gonna have to pick up the
pace
we need some kind of dark square
blockade we don't see it the night falls
now manny's still six seconds left
moving quickly
and moving randomly who has the mouse
skills
who has the skills okay we do see e5
okay and again i like it from manny
proving that the higher rated player
also sometimes has the better mouse
skills
in the end and what a game that was
indeed i think
that just about wraps up our second
round here do we do
do we have steve playing we have steve
playing a 15 minute game
steve i think with a buy opted
to play a 15-minute game but perhaps his
buy will be over
by the time this game ends i don't know
bold moves by steve
and this leaves us with four players on
a perfect score we have
manny we have patricio we have posada 12
and we have
learn chest with indian who i think i
saw in the chat so let's check out that
game these
two players on a perfect score but we
haven't had a chance to see much of
their games and it's another caro khan
it's another caracon all the players
playing the cara it went
well for black in the last game but then
we saw
that uh manny outspeed the opponent f3
strikes means a little bit odd
this line with h4h5 has actually become
quite the hot topic
at the top level many players playing
bishop d3
e6 uh bishop g5 and getting some
advantage with white we saw
magnus struggling to hold on against
takara even though he did win this game
in recent memory we also saw i think um
jeffrey zhang playing this with the
black pieces uh
recently at the highest level but
instead we see f3 which is just a a very
strange move i think
black white is trying to get some sort
of immediate g4 in
and that is what we see happen and wow
rook takes h4
complications already by posada learn
chess with indian perhaps
regretting some decisions now if rook
takes this comes with check
white takes the bishop but the rook on
h1 is simply hanging
um there are still some ideas for white
here but
i get the feeling you know rooks are
worth more than bishops so
black maybe not doing too badly maybe
not doing too badly
peter peterson in the chat room uh audi
says he won congratulations to adi
winning in round two bouncing back from
a tough first round
okay we do see black just recapturing
and again we're going to see these
problems with e6
i think appear in this game as they did
in the previous round
honestly with black i would be tempted
to simply ignore this pawn
on f5 just develop my pieces and plant
my knight there
after pawn takes f5 not only does e6
become a problem
but this f5 square is no longer
available to my knight
and i don't like that i like putting my
knights on f5
it's quite a good square manny in the
chat saying mousepad
rules apparently that is the secret to
his
quick success moving with the mouse pad
a bold decision an unpopular one i dare
say
i don't know the the question is
mousepad or trackpad what's the
difference i think a mousepad
is the thing you put your mouse on but i
assume that manny meant
the trackpad uh anyways regardless
we do have an attack on the f5 pawn we
see a check by black
i would assume something like g6 is
going to follow here
by posada i think indian is in a tough
spot here still
um black definitely has problems to
solve needs to get developed
but i think once again this is a
maneuver i would like to see
by the black pieces oh and we have a
tactic
we have a tactic by indian i missed this
bishop takes f5
this is nasty stuff it goes to show that
you are never safe in the caroucon
sadly sadly even when you're winning out
of the opening
it can be dangerous
so what do we see now by posada this is
the first real
challenge to black's position i think
yeah we don't see this move when queen
takes g8 would be a
problem such as knight e7 staying calm
and will we see knight to f5 will we see
knight i5 i wonder
what else do you do here with black you
can play knight d7 but
you're not exactly untangling your
pieces not exactly untangling this king
still looking a little bit stuck this
bishop now kind of floating in in no
man's land
we do see white capture perhaps with the
idea of bishop g5 to follow and that is
what we see
now pin on this knight on e7 the queen
is going to have a hard time moving
and i guess this is the one idea that
may
lead back back to black back to safety
but i'm honestly not convinced
interesting games in the carol khan
today
interesting games
okay we get knight d2 by white white
finally trying to finish development
here looking to bring in the remainder
of the pieces
in queen b6 ooh black is ready for a
fight here
willing to uncastle the king forever
with either
bishop takes knight option and by the
way maybe this is a good time for a
quick aside on the power of knights
versus bishops
i have a friend who tells me that even
the worst bishop um or even the best
knight against the worst bishop
often times the bishop can always trade
itself off for the knight
and that's part of why the bishop is
slightly better in many people's
opinions
and that sort of proves itself here of
course white
not even willing to give up these
bishops for the knights but if anybody
ever wanted to claim that the knights
ended up being better
white always has this option to simply
trade them off for the bishops
part of the versatility of the bishops
all right in the game though we see
black starting to maneuver around
with the knights and this was some kind
of tactic i believe
white losing the e5 pawn or sacrificing
it to open the e file
remains to be seen black of course with
the extra exchange but now
i think this last move may have been a
mistake we'll see if white
finds the idea and yeah that that's
simply a free a free rook there on c8
not
ideal we see counter punches though a
knight before check there's
this move but this doesn't seem great
either to be honest with you
knight takes a two buts i don't know
i don't know 15 seconds left what to do
in ian what to do
we get queen b8 what is this move
what is happening castles was legal for
black by the way
instead we see this but isn't this
checkmates
looks like checkmate four seconds to
find it and that is
literally checkmate literally check me
by any what a game
it's it's a tournament of upsets so far
with some really crazy stuff
let's check back in on steve's 15-minute
game seems to be going
okay looks like a french defense all
right not a part of the tournament but
you know we're still interested and what
else is going on
what games remain what games are left in
progress we still have
patrice oh this is round this is the
next round the round already ended oh my
god we're on round
four uh what was the result okay manny
fell against patricio so this leaves us
with two
leaders remaining we have patricio
against learn chess
with indian who we saw win a very tight
match
in the previous game so what's going on
here can patricio
continue the streak as the number one
rate of player in the tournament or will
indian
be the one to dethrone uh patricio by
the way
still four rounds remaining including
this one so plenty of time for all the
players
to catch up one mistake is not going to
ruin your tournament chances here
and we see a sicilian and this one is
going much more along
standard lines it looks like we have
some kind of dragondorff
is that what the kids are calling these
things some kind of dragondorff
with bishop g7 coming but also this a6b5
i don't know i don't know what the kids
are playing these days in the sicilian
i am of course a d4 player um
and a cara player so how would i know
all right we get an early b4 by black
which is fairly standard i think
although maybe this one is coming a bit
early
because knight e2 is usually um
the move white is aiming for a lot of
times players with the black pieces will
just let this b5 pawn
float for a while and let white ponder
the consequences of playing a nice
developing move like bishop
in the meantime black can play stuff
like this
use the b5 pawn to control c4 and with
an early b4 perhaps this is not coming
now i don't want to give too much away
again but i think there's a specific
idea that is generally uh played
following this b4 move and i wonder what
indian
will decide here this does feel as
though it is a critical moment
peter says sorry i'm late because i
rewatched your rook endgame stream
records the that was broken during the
stream
except for me oh yes peter referencing
an old lecture
where nobody could see it because
youtube was broken except except
for him he had to relay everything
through to the chat room that was that
was a fun night that was a fun night
peter peterson was our translator for
the chat
okay we see interesting moves we see
bishop g7 bishop h6
takes takes in knight bd7 so that idea i
was referencing
whenever you play b4 this early on it's
usually
to remove white's control of the d5
square that means you can start breaking
through
with moves like e5 moves like e5 d5
and that is the idea i expected to see
by plaque here something like e5
forcing the knight back to b3 and then
even following up with d5 in many cases
could have been very interesting but
instead we see the simple bishop g7
and now white is sort of invading with
this queen black is not making a move in
the center
and stuff like queen g7 isn't good yet
because of rick g8
but i would start being scared here with
black i would start being scared once
again i think the early idea with b4
is to remove white's control of d5 and
give yourself some more freedom for the
early pushes
but we don't see it by black and now
the pawn storm has begun with the white
pieces
and ian under some pressure again but we
saw him under pressure
in the previous game as well going down
in exchange
quite early on and now we do see black
queen side castling perhaps indian
planning
to keep the king nice and safe on this
side of the board
while white wastes their time attacking
on the king's side
drakendorf reminds me of ganondorf the
villain from the zelda games
they do share a similar name
and i hear from the other room that
disaster has likely struck
for restless behavior let's check in
there
and oof yes doesn't look ideal oh
no oh restless behavior what are you
doing can't blunder the queen like that
against
adi no less uh so sad so sad
steve's game still in progress by the
way if you were curious instead though
looking back here we have we do see
queensland castles
and king b8 by black and white is
retreating with the queen
and we do see e5 d5 and maybe i should
not have doubted
our underdog here in ian um looks like
the black king is safe for the moment
white's king's side pawn storm has
fallen a bit flat
and black is now comfortably breaking in
the center so
really strong stuff makes you wonder
about indian's 1300 rating makes you
wonder
this is not a 1300 skill level
game from what i can tell this is pretty
high level stuff
so indian perhaps a bit
low rated all right we see bishop c4 and
my eyes
immediately are wandering to these kinds
of tactics i don't know if they're very
good though
this one does seem like a better idea to
my eyes
um what will anyone play 30 seconds left
once again gonna come down to some time
pressure here
okay we do see 93 now how will white
deal with the threats
how should white deal with these threats
looks like you might just
uh be giving up a rook here whatever
white does patricio
should do it quickly 20 seconds left the
the material almost doesn't matter ooh
queen f2 trying to say that this is a
pin but i'm not convinced it does the
knight
i'm not convinced that it is the the
knight does defend and this is a full
rook now oh gosh
and it all comes tumbling down it all
comes tumbling
down 12 seconds left white makes room
for the king is escaping with king b2
there's knight c4 in any position
okay black should likely just capture
this okay knight b3 now makes a threat
gotta go quickly knight d3 instead if
i'm black i'm just taking all the stuff
i just want all this stuff off the board
no more tricky knights that are gonna
check me
just get rid of them we see five seconds
versus four
and the clock's ticking two seconds now
one second oh my gosh and perhaps
patricio with a slightly worse
connection
but the faster mouse skills what a game
patricio
with a hard earned one rating point uh
advantage
by winning this game defeats indian who
was on a bit of a tear there
on a little bit of a tear and that
should be the final game of the round
i think we are on to round five now
where again
we see manny climbing the ranks with the
win let's check out manny's game
and it's another kero khan they can't
stop playing the caro khan i love it
i love it
simon williams made a dvd on the
dragondorff it's a lot of fun
the dragondorf i wouldn't know never
played it because it's scary but
uh i feel like maybe it's not the best
opening in the world okay we see a very
early bishop g5 here generally they play
bishop d3
before bishop g5 and f6 by posada all
right anything i knew
is out the window i don't actually know
what the idea is against the immediate
bishop g5 for all i know f6 could be
correct
but i get the feeling it's not i get the
feeling it's not so once again
the normal line here as i previously
mentioned is the bishop d3 first
followed by bishop g5 but should be five
immediately i'm not as
familiar with you have to imagine
something is wrong with it
and maybe that something involves this
bishop attacking c2 for example
uh queen b6 attacks this square and
without bishop d3 included
black can pretty comfortably i think
capture on b2 and capture on c2
whereas if you try something similar in
this uh in the bishop d3 line
you're going to find that the queen on
b2 is often getting trapped that's just
my guess though maybe f6 is the right
way to do it
i suspect that it's not though suspect
that it's not
and anyone in the chat says oh no
by the way i want to shout out in that
last round adi
does defeat restless behavior and that
is a rivalry for the ages there
let me tell you that rivalry just goes
back and forth all day long
but adi coming out on top in the road to
2000 live stream tourney
so how should white manage this f6 brake
and how should black manage it as well
it's an interesting question
generally this move is not seen as that
favorable for white
but in the cairo an important
distinction is that we don't have this
nice solid bishop
hiding behind the pawns to support this
weakness here on e6 and that's why f6
in the carro is much more rare than in
the french
in the french you have this stupid
bishop sitting on d7 or something
that just defends all your weaknesses
forever it gives you a little bit more
freedom
to go kind of crazy with your f6's
now though we do see some tactics going
on uh g5
but now e takes f queen takes f
and this appears to be a counter-tactic
tactic and counter-tactic so so scary
and we do see white now is actually the
one coming out on top
with the extra exchange knight g6 is a
second fork
queen h7 might have been a nice pinning
attempt
but i think the real uh tragedy here is
again the e6 pawn
and this comes into play now when you
play the move f6 it's not necessarily
all that great for you because white can
target this weak e6 pawn
and that's going to be a problem without
a bishop on c8 it's just going to be a
problem
in many many instances all right we see
manny now with a dominating position
i imagine yeah the simple moves are good
here he just brings in
another rook to the e file all sorts of
threats in the position now
and the the white pieces are sort of
taking over looks good
for manny let's check in on board number
one patricio with the perfect score here
has the black pieces against aap
truth looking to catch up and join him
in joint first
place and we have another interesting
position this one
looks good for white my first instinct
uh although the e5 pawn may come under
some fire and it looks like another
keracon no it's a sicilian this time but
it looks kind of like some carol lines
where
black got a little bit ambitious and
played three c5 or something
but here what is going on
and no i'm completely off off track here
this is never
a 3c5 cara if the pawns were all shifted
up on the queen side by one file
then it might look like that but not in
this case
but yeah what's the problem here for
black well for one it looks like white
is
up a single pawn uh if i know how to
count
and aside from that the black pieces are
just looking a little bit sad
to my eyes it just it looks a little bit
sad to be a member of the black team
here
with all these pieces sort of stuck uh
on the first two ranks we see h6
hoping for some trades and that's
generally a good idea
when you were lacking in space just get
pieces off the board
and your remaining pieces will find a
little bit more room
to breathe checking back in on manny
down to 13 seconds by the way
not an easy task here will the mouse pad
as manny calls it pull through by the
way
if i'm manny you just you just get rid
of all the pieces like i don't know
yeah there you go manny just take off
all the pieces
make another queen your life is going to
be easier don't blunder a3 please
oh god i'll be so sad i'll be so sad if
a3 happens
oh manny okay manny's pre-moving now
this is black's opportunity
to play a3 we see a queen blunder but
it's not captured
oh boy oh boy
oh no this is it's too sad it's too
sad manny's going to go down isn't he
this is tough just too slow is manny
checking back in this game is barely out
of the opening and both players are down
to 20 seconds
i don't know how this happens clearly a
defining factor in this tournament
is the speed at which the moves are
being played it's always going to be
important
in three plus two uh some unfortunate
results
in this tournament in this tournament
because of the clock
all right we see queen c7 knight g3 and
black
trying to set up some kind of checkmate
will patricio be able to win the time
scramble once again g4
and yeah black has one idea in mind but
it's a pretty powerful idea
okay black also down a bit on the clock
plays rook d5
uh interesting in patricio goes down
that is a flag i think perhaps the
connection for patricio is not
as great as some of the other
competitors i'm seeing
some jumping back and forth whenever a
move is made but
his time scrambles finally catch up with
them you can't
win them all as they say and is that the
end of the round
maybe maybe not it is and we are on
to another round we have posada against
patricio
uh with both players on a four out of
four score
let's check back in on these standings
if they can update there we go
looks like we have three joint first
place leaders we have petrucio
with four out of five losing in the last
round ap lost in an earlier round but
defeated patricio
and now we have posada also joining them
with four out of five
i assume with a victory over uh
i was he playing manny i think he was
just playing manny
learn chess with uh indian also going
down again
and we still have this super strong at
900 by the way with three out of five
interesting games so far and it's not a
caro this time it's a french defense
no it is a cairo it's always a caro but
we saw an early g4
and black retreats the bishop back to d7
which does happen on occasion
and wow i'm starting to think that all
these people fighting for
first place are actually fans of the
show because they all play the caro khan
it's incredible it's incredible this
isn't again my line of choice
but this is a pretty common one for
black you can respond to the early g4
just by retreating back
and then you make white look a little
bit silly for pushing quite so hard
on the king's side early on this bishop
grants you a lot of defense
against f5 breaks and in the meantime
you can be the one to rip things open on
the king's side
as we see black doing here
can we see all the pawns falling for
whites but in the meantime
i think there's a square that's uh mr
patricio
is eyeing up here let's see if anything
comes of it we see takes on h3
takes and takes maybe we will see a
knight get captured as well
no we're going to see this knight land
on f5 and i'm quite happy with how this
opening has gone
for uh for black if i'm honest with you
now maybe this last move knight h6 isn't
my favorite i think i would have
preferred to see
takes g6 and then knight e7 to f5
the reason being now if something like
queen h5 comes on
you can't play g6 because the knight
hangs and if you play something like
takes takes knight f5 then g6 by white
just gets a little bit complicated you
always want to be aware of these
uh pawn breaks being a potential
opportunity for white to rip
open your king side instead we see queen
b6 and it looks like black is intending
something like queen side castles
perhaps though they may never get the
chance i assume there are sacrifices in
the air
i do think asada's idea is to leave this
knight on h6 just defending
against this these types of sacrifices
rather than jumping all the way out to
f5
at least in the short term
let's check out our other leader though
with ap truth
ap truth up against andy ruya
with the black pieces here and this one
was another scotch
okay no crazy piece sacrifices this time
except actually there were
i think no yeah this is more jonathan
tran stuff i've seen
i've seen something like this before i
think um
jonathan trans single-handedly changing
the landscape of
gambit openings by the way and what's
this
what's this is there is there a tactic
here i wonder
i wonder and yeah andy plays it
queenie8 this is backrank stuff this is
this is uh oh but wait if you take the
rook there's queen g4
i guess king f1 avoids the draw and then
this is still an issue
i don't know complex stuff going on here
complex stuff
yeah king f1 there's queen shaq and
queen e6 but we
we run away king f1 you definitely can't
take the knight because the knight on d8
hangs with checkmate
crazy stuff crazy stuff in store here i
think though it looks good for andy and
not so good for ap truth who is also
down a minute on the clock
speaking of being down a minute patricio
has to have better time management
especially
with connection issues that i've seen
you cannot be down a full minute here
you're going to get flagged
on top of that you're going to lose this
knight uh black
x of course left this knight on h6 for
the sole purpose of defending against
this stuff
and now we see black actually also able
to capture with the queen
although i don't know stuff
stuff is always scary stuff is always
scary
okay we do see takes on h6 and now if
you take back there is
bishop h5 and that's a queen posada
that's a queen alright time to turn on
the jets here you gotta
play for the flag black does actually
have two bishops
for the queen which in a blitz game is
going to give you some practical chances
to hang on for at least a little bit
but posada is going to have to play
accurately and quickly
and it looks like he's going for some
sort of defensive setup where the
bishops are defending both pawns from
behind
but i think this is going to fail if
patricio
can actively get this rook into the game
and that's why we see
uh posada willing to part with the h7
pawn now just to get active
and maybe not even parting with it
bishop e3 is perfectly playable
no we we see checkmates checkmate is on
uh posada's mind
despite the time situation maybe b5 now
and that
we do see from posada and really
ambitious play
great job activating these bishops you
have to coordinate the pieces
if you're going to survive down the
queen here but this play is not without
risk
if you start going for checkmate against
the white king you know who's
who's stopping uh the white queen from
invading as well
okay we see rook b5 willing to give up
the rook now i think this is the right
way to go for patricio
you just have to simplify things much
harder to get checkmated against one
bishop in one ruck than two bishops and
a rook
now the queen continues to invade uh
white's pawns are also dropping and
yeah black posada did everything that uh
he needed to do here to to win this game
on time and
and actually win by checkmate with that
unfortunate quick move by patricio again
the clock coming back to hurt and we see
two of our leaders
going down here as andy ruiz does defeat
a be true ap
truth in this carol khan with these
tactics
coming through how did this game go we
did see queen e6 king d2
then another check c3 takes takes
another check knight d4 and this was a
miss
this was a huge miss this was pinned
instead we saw
this with check bishop back and
again i think the clock situation played
a part with
andy ruya taking it home not without a
couple misses in there though
all right this i believe is the final
round of the events
we are running a bit short on time we do
have posada
in the lead and i think in clear first
place right
if posada can get a draw in this game
then i believe
that is a clear first place so posada
at least guaranteeing a tie for first
and
playing for more here but there are a
myriad
of people on four out of six so if
posada is to lose this we're gonna have
a big tie
up at the top and honestly if patricio
wins i think
their tie breaks may be a little bit
better patricio leading for the majority
of the tournament
that generally helps your tiebreak
situation so it all depends
on if posada can pull out this game
that being said with the white pieces
here and a fairly reasonable position
andy ruya by the way one of the highest
rated players in the tournament
looking looking to take out posada
again though you have to look at the
clocks we are early early early in this
game and andy is already down
almost a minute that being said black
seems to have more pawns i'm no
mathematician but i can count
and this looks like three for white and
four for black
and i'm not even counting this side okay
bishop f4 though
and this pawn looks like a problem maybe
white is doing just fine
and i like posada's sort of game
strategy here just keep it simple
right play quickly don't blunder and
you are assured a reasonable chance and
at least a draw which is all you need
if you're pasada all you need to do is
draw this game
is it possible to enter the tournament i
think it's a little bit late here this
is the final round
so i'm sorry silva but a bit too late i
think we're gonna do one of these every
couple to three months
so check out the next one and next
saturday not this saturday but next
saturday is the bill wright
st louis open which is going to be a lot
of fun it's going to be
a game in 30 so you speed demons
will have to slow down a little bit and
you unfortunate souls who keep getting
flagged
will have a little bit more time to
think it's going to be a lot of fun
grand master stephen zirk is going to be
playing and potentially commentating i
don't know yet if he'll commentate his
own games
but it will be a blast in the meantime
andy ruya in this final game
is up a pawn will he be able to convert
again
down on the clock looking to trade one
of the rooks off you do see opposite
colored bishops
but with rooks on the board that doesn't
necessarily guarantee you
a a half point here in black has a clear
idea to push these pawns forward andy
though taking it slow
making lift for the king not a bad idea
in a blitz game
and now we're going to see these pawns
roll up the board
posada taking a practical approach just
trying to play rook d8 shack i believe
to take off these rooks and improve the
drawing chances
posada understanding a half points all
you need here no need to go
crazy can we see c4 directly
by andy and that's not my favorite move
you want to get a past
pawn here and this does not leave you
with a past pawn
the a pawn's still contesting black's
ideas on the queen slide although i do
think bishop g3 is a
bit of a mistake and maybe andy saw
further than me entirely
now this a pawn is going to be a bit
difficult to defend we see posada giving
it
up in exchange for f5 but you know i'm
i'm tempted to take this guy now even in
the pure opposite colored bishop end
game i don't think this is a draw
anymore i think the two pawns
are generally enough to win when they
are connected like this
uh generally in this specific instance
though it might be different i'm
actually
sort of calculating some stuff and
thinking maybe it's not so easy to win
for example you can't push yet because
the b6 pawn hangs and
this is sort of a strong idea of bishop
g3 to b8 to c7
forcing a6 a6b5 and then you go bishop
a5 and then you have a big blockade
anyways none of that happened and black
won another pawn should be a winning
position
with four pawns to the good but will
andy be able to do it in 30 seconds that
is the question
king f7 doesn't seem like the way to
start to be honest you gotta start
pushing some
pushing some some dudes you know put
push your guys
okay that's free pawn that was missed by
pasada and pushing on both sides of the
board now is the correct way to go you
need to separate
the white pieces and andy making a queen
with plenty of time to spare
we're going to see uh posada go down
here i'm all but certain
though andy maybe should take it easy on
these pre-moves okay
no still mates all right careful i
advise
caution king takes would have been still
made there and said that we do see
checkmate
and where does that leave us in the
tournament that leaves us
with posada with five in the best
tiebreaks maybe
maybe the best tie breaks still some
games remaining
these two players on four points both
looking to join the leaders
with five out of five and black in some
trouble here the white pieces
seem to be kind of swarming that's a
queen trade though that's a queen trade
uh but yeah white with many more pieces
but also
less time that's a good shack the bishop
is going to fall now unless king
g8 has played and i think mate
1 was missed mate and one was missed but
the tournament's over
this was meeting one that was the final
game and i missed it who won i clicked
off of it cause i was so scared
and andy andy ruya with the best tie
breaks out of everybody
dethrones posada in the final round wins
the entire tournament and with it i
believe a raffle
to be determined at the bill right st
louis open next saturday
all right we're a little bit over time
here so i am going to get out of here
really quick
if you're watching live please stay
tuned there should be a
link to uh stephen or not stephen but
darrow
darrow's last lecture on the channel is
going to be tonight it's going to be a
lot of fun
please do check it out thank you guys so
much for watching let me know if you
enjoy these tournaments
in the comments as always my name is
caleb denby and i will see you
next time
you